we've been talking about what's going on
in Texas the Texas Republican
legislature has cut funding to
reproductive health clinics and
Republicans like to brag about small
government and fiscal conservative
conservatism but their decisions really
do kill people I I'm not being
hyperbolic we have now learned that the
maternal mortality rate has doubled over
a two-year period in Texas the rate of
Texas women who died from complications
related to pregnancy has doubled from
2010 to 2014 Texas now has the highest
maternal death rate not only of any
American state which probably wouldn't
surprise most of the people in this room
and many of the people in our audience
but of any where in what is called the
developed world the findings come from a
report that appears in the upcoming
issue of the Journal of obstetrics and
gynecology that the maternal mortality
rate increased so drastically while most
of the world most of the developed world
anyway has reduced the maternal
mortality rate excluding California were
the maternal mortality rate declined and
Texas where it went up basically the
maternal death rate per hundred thousand
births rose a little bit in in some
parts of the US and went up nearly 30%
within Texas this is absolutely insane
when we think about developed medicine
and access to health care we have this
sort of idea Rachele that it's one way
in the United States and the reality is
that depending on what state you're in
depending on how many Family Planning
clinics have been closed by Republicans
in your state it's not actually that
great of a place to have children as a
mother right well besides the fact of
taking a step backwards nationally if
you look at the statistics these deaths
are actually in older women who are
having these pregnancies whether that's
because they're entering into the
workforce or whatever Marriot of reasons
so what's interesting then is that in
Texas these women are getting pregnant I
think around 18 to 25 so that kind of
makes it even more shocking you have
these teen births but then you also have
the
the high numbers for people who are
getting pregnant a lot later in life
yeah in other words when you look at at
what age are maternal deaths more common
typically it's older women on the big on
the grand scheme of things
however it's mostly in the bluer coastal
states where women for reasons of career
and culture are delaying childbirth
until later so you would imagine that
those are the states where maternal
mortality would be higher because you
have more older women having children no
it's actually in the states that have
more teen and young pregnancy problems
where at least in the case of Texas
we're seeing it
those Jason should actually be women who
have a lower maternal mortality rate
because they are younger I mean this
sounds like another conversation for
another day you know and what else do
they have to lose oh wait they're
children you know this is a very very
serious issue and you know there's just
too many facts and figures here to
ignore it really and that's actually
Louis what we always hear right oh you
want to reduce abortion well the way to
reduce abortion is reduced the number of
pregnancies give realistic sex education
fund family planning clinics give access
access to contraception etc and when you
tell the Republicans who claim that they
want to reduce abortion that they say
that's a different conversation no it's
actually it's the conversation it's it's
the conversation it's a conversation
they're not going to have know it Texas
is the the epicenter of the the strict
father morality mentality yeah and and
of course you have the religious side of
it too they're very connected it's just
a very backwards place and most of these
politicians don't even really care about
this stuff themselves I mean it's all
about keeping the status quo getting
reelected staying in power and raising
money freezing your constituents and
killing them at the same time what's
most disturbing to me about this also
rachel is that so many we know number
one that even an organization like
Planned Parenthood ninety-seven percent
or more of what it does has nothing to
do with abortion that's number one
actually that other ninety seven percent
goes a long way to preventing the
pregnancies that ultimately lead to
abortions because one of the
prerequisites for having an abortion is
being pregnant if you're not pregnant
you're not going to happen
they actually shut down some clinics
Rachel where that some of those
individual clinics did not even do
abortions those clinics would have held
down the number of pregnancies and
ultimately the number of mothers dying
in childbirth right because it's about
health because back to the statistic
that I was talking about before for the
older women who are getting pregnant
they need to be checked for hypertension
and diabetes and chronic illness and
without these systems in place how is
this going to affect the numbers yeah
it's it's complete bizarro world
nonsense and we've been following it and
we'll continue to follow it